All right. Welcome to our session.
This is a methods workshop, and the title is "The AACR Project Genie Data
Model: A Foundation for Scalable, Structured Data Collection to
Support the Precision Oncology Revolution." My name is Jeremy Warner.
I'll be chairing this session.
Before I get started with some of my own slides, I want to extend very
sincere thanks to the AACR Genie team who are represented here,
especially Dr. Sean Sweeney, who's the director of the whole thing,
and thank you for helping make this workshop happen.
All right. So I think what I'll do is
switch to my slides
if I can. There we go.
All right. So I'm going to spend the next few minutes explaining
the who, the what, the why, and the how of the Genie Data Model or the AACR
Project Genie Data Model, which we'll really just call Genie Data Model or even GDM
for short.
So
these are my disclosures. Let's pause here for a moment.
And you can, I guess, start the timer. Yep, there we go. Great. Thanks.
All right, so the who. Well, as I already said all of this work
wouldn't be possible without the Genie team, but there are a lot
of folks that were involved with conceptualizing,
refining,
and thinking through the aspects of this data model that I'm
about to talk about.
And, I'm not going to read every single one of them by name, but I do want to
say that we put a lot of thought into who would be
involved in terms of their clinical expertise,
their domain knowledge,
the environment in which they worked.
We had folks from government as well as academia involved.
We were very intentional about including patient advocates in
this group,
so that we could get more than the provider perspective, but really get
a more holistic view.
And there you have it.
And I'll talk about the four domains in a second, but that's kind of how we broke
things out.
So what is this about? So a two-part
problem statement. Okay, so first of all,
we start from the premise that we need to measure and understand the full cancer
experience for all patients. So what does
that mean? Well, measure, right? We have to be able to quantify in
some way what is happening throughout the cancer experience.
And then understand,
is obviously taking that data and transforming it into knowledge.
I think as most folks in the room know, only about five to 10% of patients with
cancer will enroll in a clinical trial.
And even when they do, more often than not, that's just a snapshot of their full
experience. It doesn't tell the whole story.
So that's why we would look to real-world data, such as what Project Genie is
looking at.
The challenge with real-world data is that it's fragmented in time and
space,
and requires massive effort to take those data and make sense of
them.
And then, of course, the aspect of Genie that's maybe different
than some other real-world data efforts is that it's really focused on precision
oncology. Precision oncology has major and growing importance in
cancer treatment.
So that's part two of the problem statement.
So I am a big believer in prospective trials.
I think RCTs remain the gold standard,
but they're very difficult to conduct for general
cancer types, and they're especially difficult for precision
oncology.
So just as one example, this trial iPredict, which was published a month
or two ago in JCO,
took more than a decade from inception to the
publication of the results.
And even then, the results are not conclusive, right?
So there's a really great editorial that goes with this trial, I encourage you to
read it, talking about how we might be able to do RCTs in
precision oncology.
But I think real-world data has a real role here.
I think another nice thing to point out about iPredict
is that it shows that prospectively and then in the real
world, there is a very large diversity of treatment options.
So in this particular trial, in the fine print there, they actually used
157 different treatment regimens
on, I forget how many patients, but there weren't too many...
Oh, there, 210 patients. So it gives you an idea of how broad of a
spectrum of treatment you're going to see when you look at precision oncology.
So just a word about
my conceptualization of the cancer experience, which I think really
is two parallel paths.
And I have no timeline here, but as treatments
get better, as prevention gets better, the timelines are extending
from months to years and even longer.
So we've really got two parallel paths.
One is that early-stage curable path where you have an opportunity
to assess risk, to diagnose early, to treat, and then
to get into surveillance and survivorship.
And then there's the bottom path, which is probably the one
that more than half of the patients do end up on, which is the
incurable path. Not to say there aren't a lot of treatment options.
We do have transition points, right?
So we have patients who begin on the early path and transition
during treatment, during surveillance and survivorship.
From our perspective, we really think about treatment.
What does it look like?
Does it work? Does it not work? And here I've shown a hypothetical
example of multiple lines of therapy as time goes
on.
And then I think the
very important aspect of treatment of cancer is the
toxicity of it.So we've got acute toxicities, we've got
short-term or medium-term sequelae of treatment, and we've got late effects.
So you bring this all together, it's quite a complex
longitudinal situation.
So,
in order to try to address this, we created a new data model, and
maybe you will ask, I will anticipate questions. We can talk about it more.
Why another data model?
And it's a fair question, but I think, given this precision
oncology domain
and the longitudinality of it,
we did feel that we had to develop a data model that was based on
best principles,
but was specific to Genie.
We wanted to build a data model that could handle the
manual curation processes that often happen to this very
day, but also could transition us into the near future
state of health
technology-enabling curation at scale.
So as I alluded to in the beginning, we have areas of focus that we
have defined.
So we have the diagnostic variables and the diagnostic
information. We have treatment information.
We have response and outcomes, and for those
variables, we have both the conventional
metric-based variables, such as is a tumor shrinking or growing, and we also
have
patient-focused response and outcomes.
And that's also where toxicity comes in a little bit, and our next speaker will
talk about that. And then we try or
think about what social determinants of health can we capture?
What is going to be available in the medical record to
find?
What is important,
and what can we potentially gather
from other information sources, such as census
tract-level information?
So, one thing we think about a lot is we can make
specifications, but if we don't harmonize data,
we're still going to have a big challenge when we try to do a
cross-institutional registry such as Genie.
And so we really think upfront about the ease or challenge
of harmonization.
And to that end, this is a slide from a colleague in Australia
who works with the OHDSI group. And it just illustrates that even
when you
specify a standard, there can still be considerable challenges.
So here, what you're seeing are five different institutions.
They've been masked to
protect the innocent and guilty.
They all were told to standardize their medication data
to something called RxNorm, but RxNorm has many
different subtypes.
And what you see is that institution D
chose the purple subtype, which happens to be called Ingredient.
Institution E chose something called Clinical Drug,
but institutions A, B, and C, even internally, couldn't decide which of
these various flavors of RxNorm they were going to choose, and they end
up with all kinds of heterogeneity even within their institution.
So this is a challenge. You can imagine, how is it going to take to take
these five different institutions and get some meaningful merged,
harmonized data out of it? So we haven't necessarily solved that challenge, but
we've known about the challenge, and we've tried to address it
in the specifications of our data model.
So this is a really high-level overview.
We ended up with over about 750 core data elements and 13
clinical domains.
As I mentioned earlier, what we really tried to do is look at
what's out there, what works, what doesn't work so well,
and pick and choose from existing standards as much as
possible.
Our intention is to make this data model open access.
And so I think
what you'll hear about today are really two demands.
One is the specifications. So that'll be our next
talk, and that's a critical first step.
A shared vision, which really,
again, goes back to
the parent Genie group,
is essential because that's how we're going to move this type of work forward.
But then you'll also hear about implementation.
So one of our speakers will talk about how is this
actually working in their medical system.
And it's incredibly important for us to iterate on
that kind of work. So we're not necessarily going to get it perfect the first time
out,
and we're going to end up improving and also probably simplifying the data model as
time goes on.
We hope by the end of this session that you're inspired, that you will eagerly
await that open access version to come out, and that you'll try to use it
in your own system
and you'll let us know how that's going.
So with that, I'm going to transition to our first speaker.
So this is Jennifer Hoppe from AACR, and I will
bring up her slides.
And what we'll do, so I won't take questions right now, but each of our
speakers, at the end of their talk, will take some questions, and we have left time
at the end for a discussion. So thanks very much.
Good morning, and thank you for being here today.
My name's Jennifer Hoppe. I'm a clinical project manager with AACR
Project Genie, and I just wanted to say thank you all for being here
at 8:00 on a Saturday morning. And also thank you to Dr.
Warner for chairing this session.
Today, I'll just be providing a high-level overview of some of the technical
considerations that went into the building of the model.
I have no financial disclosures beyond being employed by the
AACR.So the question we're always asked is,
why a new data model? I know Dr. Warner gave some of the information
about why we chose to do this, but it really comes down to
two important components. One being really the
complexity of the cancer experience and collecting
information to provide a full clinical context about the cancer
experience, and also the evolving nature of the
needs for precision oncology research.
Obviously, the field changes quite rapidly and so a model
needs to be able to be flexible and supportive of any changes
that are needed. So to return to this idea of the complexity of
capturing information about the cancer experience,
we really understand that for a given data element that we may want
represented in the model, there is variety in both how it's
stored within the systems, whether that's the EHR,
the laboratory information system, their imaging system,
perhaps the tumor registry or even research warehouses.
But then also within that, the variety of terminologies or
vocabularies that could be used to represent any of those
data elements from ICD-O codes to SNOMED to
LOINC codes.
And as Jeremy had shared in his presentation, when we're talking
in the context of the Genie Consortium with many different sites
contributing data, every site may house a given
data element in a particular location, and they may align them
with vocabulary that differs from site to site.
So being able to harmonize all this information to have one
large data set is quite complicated,
but this is a necessary goal in order to really drive precision
oncology research needs, particularly when we think
about longitudinal treatment patterns and then, of course,
reproducible real-world endpoints like overall survival and progression-free
survival.
We considered existing strong foundations
for informing how we wanted to construct the data model.
So for instance, we looked to FHIR and
mCODE for interoperability
components, and then also the
analytical framework of the OMOP Common Data Model, as well as
regulatory reporting for USCDI Plus Cancer.
So all of these existent structures really informed the way we
were building the Genie data model so that we can expand upon it.
So the Genie data model is open source, cohort
agnostic, and the really key point here is it
implements a dual pathway architecture.
So what that means is it's able to ingest or populate
from structured data, but if there are areas
from within the clinical context that is not able to be addressed using just the
structured data, a manual abstraction component can be layered on top in
order to fill in all of those gaps.
So before we dive more into the technical component of the
Genie data model, I think it's kind of helpful to take a step back and look
at just the complexity of each of the clinical events
that should be represented within a model that's going to describe
the full cancer experience. And not only that, but consider
the temporality of collecting data for each event at multiple
time points and the additional complexity of
making sure you have all the information at each of those given points in
time to be able to better understand both the patient's
status at that point in time and the cancer status at that point in time.
So what you're seeing here is kind of a
representative timeline of all the events at
which we would want to collect information.
So all of this needs to be considered as we're kind of thinking through the
technical build.
So this slide may be a little small, but I will try to talk through
it and provide a detailed explanation.
So everything that was shown on the previous slide in terms of
specific clinical events or concepts is represented here as
well in the top row on the right-hand side.
But what you also see in the second row is examples of
where we would anticipate those data being stored, whether that's in the
EHR or within the imaging system. And the third
row here shows associated standards or terminologies that would
likely be where the
data are structured.
Underneath, again, you see each of those clinical concepts in
a box that has a list of codes underneath.
The call-out on the left-hand side blows up one of these, so hopefully you're able
to see and read that. But this example is specifically of
a prostate biopsy, so a prostate cancer
diagnosis. And what we're seeing is that by looking at
all of these various codes, you may get a little picture of
that particular procedure and cancer diagnosis.
For the LOINC code, that would tell you that this was a
prostate pathology biopsy report.
If you look at the ICD-O-3 code, particularly the topography code,
we'll understand that this location was the prostate
and then even if you look at the CPT code, you understand that the procedure
itself was a surgical pathology procedure.
So understanding all of these together really gives a full picture
of the information we're trying to capture for each of the procedures.
But again, it doesn't capture everything.
This would just be information that we could hopefully obtain in a
structured way.
So next, this is the kind of infrastructure and
implementation of leveraging those structured
dataTo be able to begin to populate the Genie data model.
The data model itself has many different clinical
domains, but we group them specifically into four areas.
One area being person-centered. So for this area, we're
capturing baseline information about that patient,
hospitalization information, any comorbidities.
Over in the treatment center domain, this is where we would capture
procedure information, your drug exposure, radiation
treatment, and clinical trial history.
Below that, you see the cancer diagnosis.
This would be all the information you would need to capture to understand that
diagnosis,
specifically the staging and then any associated tumor sequencing that
was performed.
And then lastly, specifically for our real-world data, it's
important to be able to capture outcomes.
So this section really demonstrates how we're
collecting outcomes at both the patient level
and the cancer level for
every patient that is in the registry.
On the left-hand side, we again took the example of a biopsy or
procedure and blew that up so you could see this a little bit more clearly.
The top box with the solid line represents those clinical
concepts that we would expect to be structured.
So as we were looking at that previous slide with all the lists of
potential codes, we would anticipate these top
boxes being populated with information that's already been
structured that could be programmatically collected, which would reduce, of course,
manual curation time and effort. The second box,
though, this unstructured data often lives in free text
or it could be a faxed PDF
that's a bit hard to structure
but often contains really relevant information that we need to know to understand
the full clinical context. So the data model allows for additional
manual curation on top of the structured data that's already
been ingested in order to complete that full picture and
complete those gaps.
And as I said, this could be completed through manual curation, but we do
have some centers that have explored other methods like
NLP in order to more automate this
portion as well.
Once you have both the structured and the unstructured pieces completed,
then you're able to apply our derived variable code base on
top in order to extract and
associate temporal alignment for each event, so we can
better understand, say, date of birth to procedure or date of
birth to path report. And additionally, we're able to then
implement a QA QC validation framework as well.
So you may ask, how does the Genie model fit into the
current infrastructure of existing data models?
So what we're seeing here is just an example of how
MCode leverages FHIR-based profiles
that allow for point in time
clinical data sharing. But
oftentimes it can be complex to leverage that data for some of the full
research questions demanded by precision oncology research,
particularly in the context of being able to obtain
structured regimens for treatment, and then also
your time to event calculations and your overall
survival and progression-free survival.
But the Genie data model layer A can leverage these structured
data, as we've seen, to pre-populate given data elements
within the model, but has a built-in second abstraction
layer so that any of those gaps that may exist within your
data can be fully completed so that you have a better
comprehensive picture of the full
cancer experience. And then lastly, as you see down at the
bottom with layer B,
this demonstrates that once that initial data model is
populated, the derived variables can layer on top
and provide your multi-agent regimens or line of therapy
calculations, as well as your given endpoints of interest.
Lastly, what you see on the right-hand side of the
screen is that the final data model is
structured so that ETL processes can allow for the
Genie data model to be mapped to
existing analytical frameworks like the OMOP Common Data Model.
And this is helpful because, of course, there are many data sets that are already
structured in the OMOP Common Data Model.
So it allows for repurposing of the Genie data and
harmonization with existing data as well.
So as we are providing this model
as open source and available to the public, we're also providing a
logical model component. So this is just a simple entity
diagram that demonstrates the organizational structure of the
Genie data model and all of the relationships of the various entities and
attributes. So we have 37 core entities
within this logical model and 753
attributes. And you can see there's many-to-one
relationships or many-to-many relationships.
And if we zoom in on that top left corner, this gives a picture
of particularly the report and expands
this out to show how it's been linked to other entities
within the logical model. So we're associating or able to
associate the report with, for instance, the visit
reference, the event type, the specimen reference, et
cetera.
So lastly, in summary, today, we've given a broad
overview of the general domains as captured by the Genie data
model, the person-centered, treatment-centered,
diagnosis-centered, and outcome-centered portions.And
the really exciting news is that this is being released publicly
today. So on our website, we'll have all of the materials for
accessing the data model, such as the data dictionary
of REDCap ECRF, all the curation directives, and then the
logical model piece as well. I'd also like to give a little
shout-out. We have a Genie booth over in the sales pavilion, where we're
giving demos of the Genie data. So if anyone has questions about
Genie data or this Genie data model, you're more than welcome to stop
over and chat with any of our team members for more details.
This, again, is available through a Creative Commons attribution,
non-commercial, share-alike license.
So what that means is it is
available to be adopted by anyone, adapted, and you can build
upon it for any non-commercial use.
And then lastly, we'll be working on the next phase of creating code bases
for derived variables, QA/QC frameworks.
And our
anticipation is that this will be versioned and will have new releases
on an annual basis because, of course, all of these standards and
terminologies are being updated and versioned, and we want
to ensure that our model is able to meet the needs of the community.
So thank you, and I believe we have five minutes for
questions.
And if you were to ask a question--
Thank you.
If you'd like to ask a question, please feel free to use one of the mics in the
center
aisle.
Okay, and if you could just introduce yourselves, your name, your location, and
then go ahead with your question. Yeah, please. Over here. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah, great talk. I'm not very familiar with
this one, but I have a question. When you construct your model, you
use the
data
from the unstructured data to construct data.
What method are you using to get the correct
information for your model training?
Yeah. So the question is,
how do you ensure that the data that's being collected from the unstructured data
is accurate?
So we have a variety of built-in checks as well
within--
Right now, it's constructed in a REDCap database, so there are some
QA/QC logic checks built in. But we also
have QA processes that will happen once
those data are collected that will run across the full data
set and generate queries. So if anything seems logically
inconsistent, we can then ask those who've collected that
information to re-update and provide information that's not
flagged as being an error.
And so how can this
structured information
is a
high accuracy-
Mm-hmm.
And is good for the downstream analysis or use?
The question is how can the structured data be used for downstream analysis?
Yeah, how to ensure the information,
these features used
correctly and can be-
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, is this because it's a-
Yeah. So the collection of the structured data, like
QA/QC for structured data would follow similarly as the unstructured data.
So those would be a similar process.
And then for ensuring appropriate downstream use,
we allow for the data to be public, but we don't
specify individuals' analyses. So it would be up to
those performing the analyses to be ensuring that they're using appropriate
methods.
Thank you.
I don't know. It's on. Yeah.
Yeah.
Xiaoyong Lin from Winberg Research Institute in Pennsylvania.
This is a very nice
model.
In academic setting, often we work with hospitals.
When data reaching us, the PHI are already stripped.
So does it, to
fully utilize your data model in our setting,
will you require the link through PHIs?
Yeah, that's-
De-identified data.
Yeah, that's a great question. How we've built the
case report forms for collection of the data is that PHI can be
entered into the database. But if a field is coded
as PHI, it will never be shared. So if, say, for
instance, a hospital wants to implement this for a collection of projects, but
maybe they also want to share the data externally as well, they could
enter PHI into the data capture system,
dates, for instance, but every date field, there's a
calculation that's performed. So it generates an interval in
days from diagnosis to that event.
And then if that data is shared externally, just those intervals are shared.
So anything that's coded as PHI would live in that hospital's
version of the data collection, but it would never be shared
externally.
So we wanted to ensure that the model wouldn't be, of
course, sharing PHI.
So I try to picture it. So the data will stay in the hospital, but
in the academic center, let's say one center working with ten hospitals,
how do you
picture the data exchange?
So how it functions currently is sites are able to--
So right now it's built within REDCap.
Mm-hmm.
So sites can ingest the data dictionary into their own
REDCap instance-
Yeah
... collect data into that REDCap project.
And so they have the full collection of the PHI and non-PHI.
But then upon export from REDCap, any field coded
as PHI gets masked.And then those data files are able
to then be shared, and so we're able to kind of collect that into one
spot. But the structure and the variable names, et cetera, are all
harmonized already, right? Because they're using the same data model or data
dictionary, so you can then just combine it.
Perfect. Thank you.
Okay, so we will need to move to our next speaker. Let's give Dr.
Hoppe another round. So
meanwhile, we are getting good questions online, so I think there's a
way to up vote those or add your own questions, and we will have time at the
conclusion of the next two talks for a discussion. So, thank you.
Okay, so next we welcome Jake Van Kampen from the Providence
Cancer Institute
who will talk about implementation of the Genie Data Model. Thanks.
Dr. Hoppe.
Sorry.
It's not going to work.
You've been promoted.
All right. This looks good.
Yeah, so I'm going to talk about
implementation of the Genie Data Model and at our hospital system
which is Providence,
Portland, but Providence is
kind of all along the West Coast, so we have all of the data.
I do not have disclosures.
So yeah, the Genie Programmatic Pipeline project is sort of what we're
calling this, GP3.
And the motivation is that the current process for clinical data abstraction
is slow, and error-prone, and lacks validation, and there
are benefits to multi-site harmonization using a
single data model. So the Genie Data Model establishes this consistent
data schema that we can all implement
and then
use for analysis across more data
if everybody has the same data format.
So GP3 aims to replace or augment the manual data
curation process
so we can scale to larger cohorts and have
better data quality.
So, before, this was taking manual
clinical data abstractors sometimes eight hours per case.
And the data quality and consistency
was not really measured
or it's harder to measure in that manual setting.
And so this GP3 implementation, we're able to extract
data for many thousands of cases in minutes, and
obviously, that is more scalable.
And so also systematic evaluation of the
data quality and consistency is something that we're interested in
while we're doing this implementation so that we can understand
all of our data and how it fits into the model.
So kind of high-level data flow
is we have a bunch of source data in the Providence system that is
synergized into a clinical data warehouse
in the Snowflake data platform.
And so our GP3 project here is
extracting attributes from the Snowflake data warehouse and mapping
them onto the GDM in a
programmatic way.
And we can also
do a lot of good validation throughout this whole process, and then we
prepare the data for upload
to whatever format it needs to end up in.
We can also export into REDCap for
the manual validation as
a backwards compatibility for the existing
process, basically.
Some of the technical components that we use to implement the pipeline are
GitHub, and
Snowflake, and REDCap, and of course, the Genie Data Model.
We're
making more use of the AI tools, so GitHub Copilot
is the
AI code tool that we're using to accelerate this
process, and it
lowers the activation energy for doing higher quality
software engineering best practices basically across a project like this.
So
yeah, the architecture
overview is basically we're looking through our clinical
data warehouse and mapping the attributes in SQL
code,
and we're doing this by category or form
or instrument as they're referred to in the GDM.
And then we're staging those tables into intermediate tables back in our data
warehouse so that we can export, validate,
and report on the completeness of them.
So we use Python to orchestrate this whole pipeline,
do the validation and the QA,
and then again, yeah, the data's staged back into the GDM-aligned
tables.
So this is just a screenshot of our Python project.
We started doing this manually like, okay, what
SQL query do I need to write to extract the attribute
from the GDM? And then we started using AI to help us scaffold these
mappings and then built the pipeline from there.
And there are lots
of complexity around how to find the correct
attribute for the GDM in the healthcare
system.
We have tumor registry sources and the medical record
from Epic and other.
And so we had to sort of implement a hierarchy if
data is
coming from one source in a better way than another source, and
it's complicated.
This is an example of extracting-Cancer type
according to the GDM schema using ICD codes.
This is one way we can do that.
And each attribute has this transformation logic in SQL, and
then because they can have multiple sources, sometimes we have to have this
fallback mechanism or source priority,
basically.
And this allows us to enforce the schema definition
as code. So this is one form of schema validation.
As we run the pipeline, we can have a basic completeness
report. This is an example of running the pipeline on thousands of
rows
for thousands of patients,
and saying, "Okay, what does it look like
across all the attributes, across all the forms?
How complete is the data model?"
This allows us to sort of spot-check
as we introduce new attributes into the pipeline from the
GDM.
Like how complete are they? And if something looks
really out of whack, then we can go
and check on that particular attribute and fix it.
We implement a couple different validation sort of frameworks.
One of them is the schema validation, like does
the attribute align with the schema?
That's pretty
easy to do because the GDM has a nice definition, which
is now public
which is cool.
So yeah, this is easy to implement as code.
Does everything make sense? But the next validation framework is
sort of the record-level consistency,
and this is the kind of thing that Genie does
already for
cohorts like that. But
if we do it at the time of implementation, it allows us to
review
our process
and iterate on it
in a better way. So, if we see something like dates that
don't make sense, we know that our data source
might be messy over there, which is very common.
So
doing those types of validation allows us to do temporal quality tracking.
We can build a database of
our validation metrics over time, and as we
add new attributes, we can see how our quality improves
over time, and that is helpful. It helps us sort of highlight
the places that we need to improve our process.
And it integrates into our software development life cycle
in a natural way.
This is an example of a QA check where
we have a weight in pounds that's outside of the
plausible range. So what's going on over there?
We've got to go back and look at the source of this attribute
from our data warehouse and see, okay, why are these values
funky?
This happens all the time. So if we can find a better
way to translate the existing value or establish a rule set
for that particular
spot in the database that has them coded a different way,
we can
accommodate that type of thing.
Another thing we did was generate a lineage
parser for our pipeline. So
if we annotate the SQL code correctly
according to the GDM, we can run this lineage
parser tool, and it will automatically document the source
of all of our attributes from our data warehouse.
This is helpful for us because
it's hard to keep track of where everything is.
And
as we add new attributes over time, the sources will change, the
source hierarchy will change,
and so if we can document this live
in a programmatic way, that is helpful.
So an example of annotating
some SQL code with the GDM
attribute name and some other things about it, and
the lineage parser extracts that from the code and creates a little
table we can look at. It's nice.
So we really did use GitHub Copilot
to help us
write a lot of this code, and it's interesting because
just six months ago
this kind of thing wouldn't have been possible with the
existing tools. But the modern implementations of
the AI that are available are very
impressive, and they
increase the quality of the project and the
project management. So
it's a very transformative tool, and it's interesting to see how we can
apply it to our work,
and this project has been enabled by that.
Some results here,
that a lot of the clinical data is really messy,
so finding ways to
monitor
and accommodate that, all the edge cases, is kind of
the challenge. A lot of the attributes in the GDM are automatable,
which is nice.
That is
kind of
also a function of the quality of our existing data warehouse.
So we do have a nice data warehouse that captures data
in
a lot of different-- We have an OMOP implementation.
We have the Epic Clarity tables and things like that.
So
validation is important, and AI tools are helpful.
Data access is really the critical thing.
How do you-find your data, it's almost the
majority of the project.
So improving the consistency,
and the attribute coverage, and validation
are all things we're interested in continuing to do for this project and
potentially,
extraction
of attributes from
unstructured data is an interesting
avenue. Because we have so much structured data,
this isn't as much of a priority because we do have a lot of
really well-structured data, but it's an interesting thing to think about is how
can we
extract
more features from unstructured
data in a way that is accurate? Like the question
that Jen got was, how do you train a model
to extract the value correctly? And that's an open
problem. It's not easy. And so,
one thing that helps with that is this
validation and observability of the whole process.
So the more we report on
accuracy and write
rules for validation, the more you can
evaluate a method like that.
So how to enable GP3 at your site is basically,
do whatever you can to find your data. And that's not easy.
And so you got to work with all the security teams and the
IS people. And
oftentimes data exists in silos, and we
know that that's a problem, and so you have to figure out a way to get
as much access as you can to implement something like this.
And that has been a challenge for us, but we did figure it out
eventually.
And a lot of times,
we have access to data sources, but the data source isn't super
well-documented
or supported or something, but it is real important data that we need
to access. So,
these are all challenges. And yeah,
we've used AI to help us do this. Like help me explore my
database
to find out what's there.
And that's an interesting idea
and it does allow you to do that a little bit more
quickly than just
writing a bunch of code yourself and trying to figure it out.
The validation logic is really important for implementation of something like this
because of how messy the data is or can be.
And yeah, tracking the data completeness allows you to
iterate faster.
These are all of my acknowledgments of all of the people on our team,
and then, of course, Kelly and Jen and Sean and everyone at AACR.
So yeah, thanks.
If there are any questions.
Over here in the audience, someone who knows something about Geni maybe?
All right. Ken Geegle, Dana-Farber.
Great talk. It's hard to map structured data to other structured
data.
Yeah, it is hard.
Maybe along those lines, to what extent does the mapping you've
undertaken tackle a synthesis problem, right?
I'm thinking of
how many cancer diagnoses has this patient actually had?
It's one thing to extract the number
of cancer registry rows they have and the number of
unique ICD codes they've ever had for a cancer from
Epic, but
I guess I'm wondering,
has your pipeline tackled that problem, or is that left as an exercise to the
downstream user of the data?
Yeah. Finding the
primary cancer type associated with that particular case
is a task because like you're saying, there can be many
cancer codes
for a particular patient in
many different formats across many different data sources.
The tumor registry can differ from the Epic source, can differ from
the
unstructured
note, right? So,
the process of deciding which one is the most important,
it does require
understanding all of your data
sources really well. So that's like,
yeah, okay, we
can write a bunch of code to do this extraction, but really the majority of the
work is understanding
our hospital's data sources really well, and that's
hard.
So I don't know how to answer it otherwise. Yeah.
Okay. Sounds like it's maybe more the initial
row-level extraction, but maybe we can talk more about that.
Yeah. It's both. Yeah.
Thank you very much for your great talk.
So I have a quick question to how to develop some
biomarker by use of your Geni
GitHub system. So my question is, if we
would like to develop a
companion diagnostic biomarker based on your
GitHub database, can you tell us how to develop
and step-by-step process
if you have some genomic information or
messenger RNA information with patient response or
non-responder,
how can we develop by use of your information?
Yeah, that's a good question, and that's-That's really what
the Genie data model is going to enable.
So once we have
a lot of different sites implementing the Genie data model, we'll
have harmonized
cancer data across a lot of different institutions, and then we can
start to do the research.
Because even in our hospital system, we have lots of different
cancer patients and lots of cases for different cancer type, but it's still not
enough.
If I wanted to train an AI model on
ovarian cancer,
I don't really still have the statistical power to do that within
just one pretty big hospital system.
So the research is enabled by the GDM, and that's
going to be a good future direction, is once we all start using the
model like this and we have enough data there, we can do
more rigorous data science things
like how do we find a biomarker? Yeah.
We have time for one more question. Thanks.
Hi, this is Sean from Karis Life Sciences.
So we
encounter a lot of problem trying to harmonize the claims data with the
EHR, EMR data. So do you guys
have a label for your records?
Is this complete, high quality or low quality
so that users can follow to filter for high-quality
claims?
Second question is, if there
is
patient with multiple cancers, that patient record will be
existing in different
tables?
Yes. Well, in our data warehouse at ANO
at Providence, not related to the GDM, the data
source
has a varying quality. And so,
it's something that
we try and contribute back to the
constructors of our internal databases, is how can we improve the
documentation for this really nice resource?
Okay, nice resource, has a lot of structured data, isn't really well-documented.
So
how can we recontribute back to our hospital system by
helping them document the data sources better, is something
that we're trying to do also because we're consumers of the data, and so, yeah.
Do we have a column with saying this is a large gap, it
likely to be clinical trial or something, so that people use
the data can realize those kind of
qualities existing in that patient record?
Yeah. It will be
one of the largest sources of heterogeneity
in a Genie data model implementation is
patients that don't receive
this treatment don't have the record
for treatment data or patients that don't have encounters but do have
diagnoses don't have encounter data.
So that's
going to be the nature of the data.
Yep.
Thanks for that last question. I spent a lot of my time thinking about the absence
of data and an informative missing-ness.
It's really hard to tell the difference between something that's missing
because it didn't happen and something that's missing because it's missing.
So we can talk more about that later.
All right, so we have our last speaker right now, and then we'll again have a
discussion. So please do keep putting those questions online.
I'm answering a few there, but we'll have more for discussion later.
So now I want to welcome Dr. Hacker Busch from
the University of Lübeck. Did I pronounce it okay?
Who's going to give us the European perspective here. Thank you.
Yeah, good morning, everybody. Thank you for the kind introduction, and thank you
for inviting me to present basically the Euro perspective on data and
precision oncology and what Genie has to do with it.
Overall, first of all, I have nothing to disclose, and then we can just
jump right into it. So as we've seen before in these
talks, that Genie is basically conceptual origin of all
data for precision medicine. They were the first to really show that
you have a patient journey that you can model with standardized
data. This old idea from 2017 that you have data that
you generate in the clinic that you clean and then visualize, say, using C
Bioportal, and then that you can request the data, annotate it
properly, and release it out for secondary use and
research. That still holds also with the new data model.
And the ACR Genie was the first to really show that
federated, multi-institutional, international networks are possible
with clinical data for precision oncology.
And they showed this proof of principle for this feasibility of this
large-scale, real data and integration, and they also showed,
which is important, that there are main bottlenecks, that is data harmonization and
data governance. And it's particularly the second
point that if you look to Europe, that this is
important to do this data harmonization and governance.
Now,
looking at the European health systems, it's a data multiverse.
So whereas Genie is one consortium, one GDM,
and that you can basically combine institutions and have international
networks, you have also institutions that collaborate from Europe with the
Genie
project. There are additional challenges in the EU.
So you have national data sovereignty rules, you have fragmented
healthcare systems, you have separate cancer strategies.
Each country and hospital has their own sequencing pipelines,
and you have data protection constraints.
And really,
this data in Europe is so-scattered that
the EU even started their own Cancer Care Beacon project a couple
of years ago just to get to know what Europe knows about cancer
data. So in that project, they established a
Beacon wiki in which the stakeholders for cancer
data, the patients, researchers, policymakers, and data providers
put in what type of data they have, what type
of data they would like to have, and how we can basically gather
this
and harmonize this data. So with this
mapping of cancer data across Europe, one can then go about
and harmonize data. And in the meantime,
the European health data is really on a clear road
or a unifying road ahead that patient
data should be layered
in four spheres. So
the primary sources of health data and
health data for precision oncology comes from the hospitals and
registries. So you have the electronic health records, you have the omics data,
images, and registries. This layer is then superseded by the
national cancer nodes. So these cancer nodes should
harmonize and integrate the data, provide the governance.
So they are the genie-like structures.
In Germany, for example, you have the German Network for Precision Medicine, the
network of the university hospitals, and Genome.de, I will talk about
later. Then the third layer in Europe is the federated
research infrastructure. There you want to connect these
national cancer nodes, these national initiatives,
and do federated analysis and offer computational service
that unify all of this heterogeneous
data. And the outer layer is the European
health data space. That is the grand vision that across Europe we
have one unifying data model and seamless data
integration of all health data there is.
Now in this talk, I will now go from the outer to the inner layer again and provide
you examples of
consortia that deal with the respective data.
Now, starting with the European health data space.
I know this is a very busy slide, a very busy picture.
I took this straight from the website of the EU, and it's
basically a data dream come true that is envisioned
here. The European health data space was first mentioned in
2020. It's entered into force last year,
and it should be completed, if everything goes according to plan, in
2030. And I know this is really a grand task.
So what you have here is that in the center is basically
the patient,
which is the data holder, and the patient should have a health wallet.
And into that wallet, you enter all of the primary healthcare data from
hospitals, from doctors, and other sources.
Now, the holder should
have individual control over their own data according to data protection
laws, and this data should be entered seamlessly and
interoperably, whether the patient is in any country of
the EU. The user should also have control over the
data of the secondary use, and if that data is free to use,
then it can be used for research, can be used for industry
or other purposes, and it should be used according to the FAIR principle that
is findable, accessible, interoperable, and reusable.
So that is the grand idea. Whether we can manage by 2030, I
don't know. We'll talk about it in a couple of years.
Now, it is well known that this grand task cannot be
executed by itself. So there are helper consortiums that are
trying to harmonize the data, in particular for precision
oncology. There is this CANDLE consortium, which has
started last year. CANDLE stands for National Cancer Data
Node Developers, and it's coordinated by
Health-RI in the Netherlands, and it
basically unifies 40 partners around 20
countries in Europe, as you can see on the right-hand side.
These national cancer nodes are either coming from the various
institutions, a couple of them are shown on the bottom right,
or they are managed through the health ministry of the countries themselves.
And the idea of CANDLE is to generate national hubs for
harmonizing data to connect these clinical genomics and
molecular imaging data to provide tools and fair research data sets.
And CANDLE itself is then embedded in even higher structure, the
Oncan and the European Cancer Patient Digital Centers.
The Oncan Connect project, which also started last year,
means understanding cancer. It is now the idea that the
national cancer nodes put all of the data in this federated
service, connecting all of these national data, and
then we can have cross-country queries in federated
research.
Oncan is also then accompanied by the EU
Cancer Information Portal. That is the idea that you
want to empower patients and improve health literacy.
So we have the medical guidelines, patient outcomes, and evidence-based
resources, take AI quality control, and then build a
library that allows patients to inform themselves about prevention,
diagnosis, and treatment.
So basically having patient empowerment, having federated data access.
This is now the grand scheme, how we can
create precision oncology in the EU.
So you have the data users per country.
You have the CANDLE national cancer nodes, and they should build
then European health data space,
secure data models, and this then integrates together with the
Oncan and EU-CIP platforms to reduce the burden of cancer in
Europe. So this is what is currently ongoing.
Now-Of course, on the national level, there
have also been
projects that really try to bring precision oncology
into healthcare. And one of these interesting model projects
in Germany is GenomeDE. It's a model
project for genome sequencing for rare genetic
diseases and cancer, and it wants to bring precision medicine in
the clinical routine and certified hospitals.
So 27 hospitals across
Germany, as shown here on the right, are allowed to sequence patients,
whole exome, whole genome sequencing, and from that derive
special or individual treatments.
It started in 2019, and last year in '25, the first
patients were enrolled. And the interesting fact is that the health insurance
basically pay for this sequencing, and they pay for the
sequencing if the data
per patient is uploaded into genome data centers.
And actually, it was the Genie data model, which
basically was a blueprint for the data that has to be uploaded to the data
center here. Plus, additionally, you have to upload patient
consent, reimbursement
information, and therapy recommendation, and this data upload is mandatory.
That means that
in this model scheme of the GenomeDE, you get money for data.
So you get around
7.5 or 8.5k euros per
patient sequencing, depending you do exome or whole genome sequencing,
and the number of patient money you get per year is capped.
So in our hospital, we get roughly 3 million euros per year.
And it works like this, that if the patient enters the hospital,
they're sequenced, and the therapy recommendation is finished.
Then you upload the clinical data and the genomic data to the
respective data nodes. The data nodes do quality
control, check whether the data is there or the variables have been filled in,
and then they return a confirmation token, and only when this confirmation
token has been returned, health insurance will pay.
So this is actually a very good way to enlarge
your data sets
with precision oncology data, which you can then use later
on for research. And the vision for this project is to
connect it to the national data nodes and the European health data space.
Because, as I can say, the data implementation at this,
as right now, still needs a lot of work in this
research perspective. How this actually will work in the end, and the data
format that can be exported has not been fixed yet.
So a lot of work ahead. The last project I want to talk
about is basically Genie with a twist.
So the German Medical Informatics Initiative that tried to
structure clinical data also had a use case for molecular tumor
boards, which sequenced cancer patients for individual therapy.
And the question there was: how can we standardize workflows?
How can we
develop a tool that can visualize large data, is compliant with open
standards, and integrates into hospital IT?
And the choice was basically to use cBioPortal from the
Genie Project and adapt it to molecular tumor boards.
And as such,
we now have enlarged the cBioPortal
for molecular tumor boards and patient care that we take
the grant
method that we can-- or this visualization of patient history and clinical data,
the access to the latest database information for variants, for
case preparation and presentation,
and then add a tab for structured therapy recommendations.
So we document this therapy recommendation directly in
the cBioPortal as a free text and also
as a structured information for therapy priority, molecular reasoning,
treatment evidence level, according to OncoKB and the
literature. For that, we built a FHIR server within cBioPortal
and have some restful interfaces to communicate with hospital ITs.
We augmented cBioPortal with clinical trial search that we can
enroll patients in
clinical trials if possible,
and this really proved to be highly efficient to run molecular tumor
boards, and particularly in clinical care, time is money,
and you need to be efficient here. And it has been in production for
four years. We have more than 2,000 cases, and we are trying to roll out
cBioPortal in the MTB version across Germany within a
PM4Onco consortium.
So this
already brings me to the end, showing the perspective of
the European or EU way of
using precision oncology data for precision medicine.
The lesson we have learned, particularly from the ACIR Genie, is
that Genie has shown that multi-institutional data sharing is feasible,
and with these layers of data sharing and the Candle project,
the Uncan project, the EU is now trying to scale this up to
up to 20 nations. The second lesson is that the
sustainability of such approaches requires incentives.
With a GenomeDE project, we get money for
data, and this reimbursement actually ensures that there's a
constant flow of data coming directly from the
medical doctors, and this creates also the operational infrastructure for
patient care. And last but not least, cBioPortal is a very good
foundation you can build on. You can extend this data, bring it into patient care,
for example, adapt it for clinical routine, and really enlarge
patient care with that. And
through that, I hope I could show that we have the basis with the
AC Genie data model, which provides the standards,
and the EU tries to bring federated infrastructure.
And also, we are on the local level.
We perform local adaptation to make-This idea
clinical actionably. And with that, I think one can enable this
really transatlantic real-world evidence at a large scale for better
patient care.
So with that, I would like to acknowledge the people
that are working on this
in my group, Medical Systems Biology, throughout Europe,
and particularly, I want to acknowledge the Netherlands Candle
Consortium, Gerrit Meijer and Lifang Li, and thank you very much
for your attention.
We have some time for questions for our speaker, and then we will have a
discussion for all of us.
Go ahead.
Yeah. Thank you very much. It's highly impressive to
see how far
you have gone in Europe to integrate this model into patient care.
Yeah.
I'm just curious,
do you have any data to demonstrate the effectiveness
of
data validation and QA
in this model, especially that is going
now into the patient care?
Because the good output can be
easily compromised if those datas are now well validated, and there is no
effective internal
QA. Thank you.
Yeah.
So that's always a good question, whether this precision oncology approach is
improving healthcare and
survival of the patients. I'm mostly working in molecular tumor boards,
and there we have proven that individual therapy indeed prolongs
the life of the patients.
At the point where molecular tumor boards can actually act on patients, where they
can enroll the tumor boards, it's usually that time when
you cannot heal them, but at least with the right
therapy, in several cases, you can really improve the quality of
life and the survival. We can show that it's statistically
significant, and so I'm pretty sure that for all of precision
oncology, if you enroll the patients early and give them
individual treatment, I think patient care
could be very much improved in oncology.
I'm actually more concerned with
the data validation.
Yeah.
You mentioned harmonization of the data, which of course is-
Yeah
... very impressive.
But I'm concerned about
how those datas, because the datas are coming from different sources-
Yes
... from the clinic, from individual people-
Yeah
... that are contributing to the database.
Mm-hmm.
I'm a little bit concerned about the validation and the internal
QA of the model.
Yeah.
That is a big concern, and this is so far an
unsolved problem. So we're doing a lot of interlaboratory testing where we
compare pipelines for the analysis for precision oncology.
We do see heterogeneous results, and maybe
if we come back next year or the year thereafter, we have more results.
So I know for our case in Germany,
harmonization of the data, the different workflows, and the absence of any gold
standard for the analysis is still a big problem with that.
And it's one of the challenges for the futures.
Over here, please.
Hi, I'm Kshitij or Rishi from Four Base Care. So quick question.
Yeah.
Congratulations first on the data model.
I was definitely not asking why another data model. It's very much needed.
Just one question on the impact when you're seeing implementation or
when you will see implementation in the clinics.
Do you have ways in which it can be
normalized across population types?
Because there'll be different people coming from different populations with
some historical information.
Yeah.
Very good question. So far, not. So far,
we work basically in a youth-centric way.
I know about initiatives then in the United Arab Emirates that also try to
implement precision oncology projects, but beyond that, I
think this is something that other countries also will have to adapt and
then also look for gene or population-specific effects, yeah.
I think I can extend this to the Project Genie team as well-
Yeah
... if I may. I know it's part of the questionnaire here, but still.
Yeah, that's a really good question, and it was something that we were also mindful
about when
thinking through what to include in the data model, specifically building out a
more robust section for capturing social determinants of health as well,
and being able to provide more of a picture of each of
the patients that are in the registry.
But again, as we've kind of talked about,
when we're able to have larger amounts of patients with this level of
detail, then hopefully we can have some analyses that will shed some more
light on that.
Sure. Thanks.
Thank you.
Great talk. So a question about the MTP and
the
BioPortals which you developed.
So for this one is included
genomic datas, EHR datas and--
Okay. So these models-
Mm-hmm
... how
we can use it to answer what kind of question, and
how about the
model performers?
Okay. How we can use the BioPortal for basically answering
then oncological questions. The good thing is the
molecular tumor board that we use it for in the end is basically just like then a
registry study, and you will have the comp-Complete patient
cohort. In this case, we have 2,000 patients at your fingertips, and the
power of cBioPortal is that you can then compose your own cohorts
and ask your own questions regarding mutations,
regarding clinical data. And we could, for
example, the coalitions in our code already easily now look, okay,
what's the influence of high or low TMB on survival of certain mutations and so
on. So it's really now easy, once we have this data prepared through
cBioPortal, to then use it for follow-up studies, and that's really the
benefit that everybody then can really use that data.
And sorry, your second question again was?
Yeah. So always we build a function model-
Yeah
... and the model performance is very hard to evaluate.
And
so how about the model performance?
Is
good enough for the clinical use?
What do you mean exactly by model performance in terms of
like a T-wise, so to say, what's the server capacities
we need to have or?
For example, we want to know in your slides, you see the
treatment and this drug response, this one.
Yeah.
I ask this question, and he will give us a result,
but how accurate about this
result output?
Oh, that's a good question. You answer that per
patient. It's hard how-- And usually, it's
individual therapy, so you always have some patients which respond well to this
therapy, and overall, we could show that statistically, again, the patients
that receive individualized therapy, that they have a better chance of survival and
basically live longer. So that is basically reassuring
that you are on the good or right track with precision oncology.
But then again, really,
we need more confirmation data and follow-up studies, so I
have to admit that. Jeremy, maybe you
wanted to add to it?
No, I think it makes me think again of the prospective trial I
mentioned at the beginning, the iPredict, because really, the more we measure
and the more treatment options we have, we will be in the N of 1
territory.
Every tumor, every patient will be
individualized.
One of the powers of Genie and any effort
that creates cohorts is that you can
try to at least implement some kind of similarity measure.
But that will get harder the more knowledge we bring to the table.
So I think that's-- Again, we just have to build on what we know.
So that's why a molecular tumor board is
critical, but it's the beginning of that path.
So you really have to collect what happens.
Why was the decision made? What was the confidence in the
decision? And then what was the result of whatever was
decided, treatment or otherwise?
So I think
we'll pivot now. We'll pivot into general questions, general discussion.
So maybe-
Yeah
... you can come join us again on the podium.
And thanks again to our three speakers, please. Okay.
So
there's a few questions online, and I'm going to ask one and transform it a bit.
So the question is,
does Genie have the capability of handling tumor transcriptomic data?
And I'll actually just say more generally, that's a question about extensibility of
the model. How are we going to bring in new data sources?
There are existing data sources such as whole slide
imaging, radiology imaging. Those are available to
most medical centers right now, but they're not necessarily incorporated.
So to Jen, two parts. One, how extensible is
the model? And two, because of the licensing
allowing adaptability and extensions, have we
thought about if users make changes or
extensions, how would we bring that back into the parent model?
Yeah, it's a great point.
This is a little bit new territory for Genie to be opening
this up to the community. But we would, of course, recommend
if people have made improvements to share that back to us.
As I said previously in the presentation, we do anticipate updating the model
annually. So if there have been components that
others find very useful for their data collection and would like to share back to
the consortium for integration into the model, that's certainly something we would
consider. And then in terms of how extensible is it,
right now the model is structured within a REDCap
eCRF primarily.
And if your site has those capabilities to deploy
the model internally,
any teams can make additions to the model as they would see
appropriate.
I have a
broad almost philosophical question about data models, not really specific to the
Genie data model, honestly, but relevant.
This usually attracts blank stares when I ask it, but I understand why.
As
I guess AI technology is improving,
at some point,
might we
not need to work as hard at
creating structured data models,
which is a lot of work and is really hard, as you guys have described.
But rather think about an infrastructure where the
underlying data are left essentially messy at their
source,
and for specific questions,
you call on a team of AI agents to do the
use case specific data wrangling and extraction,
acknowledging how do you make sure that's high
quality and so forth, and maybe that's an important issue.
Thoughts on this
use of ontologies in general question?
There are thoughts, right? So it kind of gets back to what I'm saying.
So if we want to have a cohort development, if
we want to define similarity between patients,
if we want to
essentially do those tasks, which is the
task of
grouping, that's fundamentally in a
common language, that's where you need an ontology.
If you instead want to consider every patient as an N of one,
it may not be necessary, but I do think that makes
less sense. Because what I think
we all feel is that we can learn from what's happened before and use
that knowledge in the future,
and we've done that
for decades in cancer by grouping.
And I think we'll continue to do that.
And so that's the philosophical answer to your philosophical question, is that if
the goal is to learn from what's come before to extend to the future, I do
believe ontologies will always be necessary.
I would be curious to hear from others on the panel.
Thank you. That's a very interesting and good question.
I have been asked this before. Why not use AI to just extract all the necessary
information? But I think it's also think about the people that have to enter this
information that the medical doctors, and they also need to have the mindset
that the number they put in there, depending on a set molecular test,
is the correct one, and that they think about this data to be reused later
on. And if they work sloppily and just write their general
letters and for about their patient, you will end up with garbage in and garbage
out, and the quality of the data overall will deteriorate, and
then we are left with nothing. So that's basically my personal opinion on this.
So really make the medical doctors aware that we need numbers, precise
numbers, and for any ontology that we put in there, and only then
we can ensure that the data quality stays high.
I think that's great, and I'd like maybe Jake to comment on that because that's
maybe the secondary use of models is to pick out
inconsistencies that can and should be fixed.
So I think your example--
I wish I could have had my glasses on when you showed that slide with the percent
unknown or the percent missing per variable-
Oh, yeah
... because I think that's so informative.
And when data don't make sense, like the weight example that you gave.
Right.
There's an opportunity there to not just
stop your analysis, but actually go back-
Right
... and
teach folks how to document better, right?
Right.
Your question is interesting because
I think about this not in this context, but
in terms of how we were using AI tools
to improve our workflows in another way.
Once it became easier to do some tasks
with AI, the question is, okay,
can that replace
our-- We
had the
intuition to maybe develop a framework to do this
thing. But then if AI can just do the thing really quickly, why
develop the framework? That's the root of your question.
And so that does potentially scale to
big data projects like this in the future if
the AI tools become super
useful. But
like we're talking about, having structure is really nice because it allows
us to ask pointed structured questions,
report on them, and
validate things better. And the data already is messy, and that's great.
But
I hear what you're saying because it's interesting.
Please.
Hi. Raymond Fennema, Netherlands Cancer Institute.
First of all, congratulations to ACR Genie and all
of the progress that has been made. That's really impressive.
And it's also nice to see how this has inspired
European centers to think through how to fill in
the tasks for EHDS.
So if we think a little bit further
at this point in time, obviously Genie is focusing on
cancer patients. But if you think about how to deal
with data for patients, there is also other big diseases.
So to what extent have you been interacting with the field of cardiovascular
disease or neurodegenerative disease?
How can we use this more in a generalized way?
So
we thought we'd accomplish something by getting medical oncologists, surgeons, and
radiation oncologists in the same room so that...
No, it's a great point.
The model
we mentioned comorbidities. We're really thinking about not just a
cancer diagnosis, but everything that comes with it.
But I think you've made a great point.
We should
tackle all of medicine, right? Right, Jen? What's the ACR's plan?
Well, I would say that it's purposely built and made
available so that you can adapt it if you so choose.
So for those sections or modules within the
model that are relevant across different diseases outside of
oncology, certainly teams can pick that up and
utilize it. And if there's additional disease-specific
modules that should be created for other non-cancer diseases,
that could be created and added on as well.
I think it's a really great question, and I'm sure something that we would love to
continue to have a conversation about.
I have a quick pointed question to Jen.
The existing Genie data, will it be put into the
GDM?
Yes, we're working on making all of our existing data sets.
So
beyond just the main registry, we do have quite a few
different cohorts of patients who are in the main
registry but have additional clinical annotation for them.
And typically, these have been captured using bespoke data models
throughout the years for specific research questions.
So we do envision harmonizing all those data and making them
accessible through the Genie data model format.
Sherman Mayo, Florida. Since we're looking at orthogonal
directions, fantasizing how much could be done, I'm wondering if
you're thinking about adding some critical antecedents that
exist prior to cancer diagnosis,
smoking, obesity effect.
The outcome of these tumors, too often in oncology, you
work with oncologists, they think the patient's disease state
starts when the tumor comes out. Of course, that's not right.
So, there are some basic data elements you could add
that might really be very transformative here.
Yeah, that's a great point and something that we were considering when developing
the data model.
So currently, a lot of our data comes from tertiary academic centers,
meaning that what exists within those EHRs is usually the type
of data that we have access to. So if there was data from two, three
years previous, say from a primary care center or from a different treatment
center, that may be hard to capture.
However, capturing comorbidities or height and weight at
point of diagnosis to be able to then calculate BMI,
smoking history. If those things are documented within the
data that we have available to us, there's a space within the model for that to be
reflected. And typically, right now, it is time pointed around
point of diagnosis.
But yeah, capturing the patient journey
before
is difficult because they may not be in the
hospital system yet .
So, and if they are, maybe not for that reason.
So it's hard to find that data.
And again, this gets to that bigger issue of informative missingness and, in this
case, unhealthy patient bias or the opposite, which is healthy patient
bias. And
many people do not encounter the healthcare system until their cancer
diagnosis, whatever happened before.
Actually, that's informative, right?
So someone who was regularly attending their primary care doctor
may be a very different phenotype than someone who was not, right?
So for all the reasons you mentioned. So I think that's very important.
We're really getting down to the last minute here, so maybe our
final question here. Thank you.
Henk-Jan van der Ham from The Hive.
I have a question on how do you envision the collaboration with
industry through this model? Because you're making it available, and I think most
of what I've seen this morning is about public institutions and
hospitals, but how do you see this happening, collaboration with industry?
That's all I have.
That's a tough one.
Yes. So the model is shared with
the Creative Commons attribution non-commercial
license. So if an
organization or a company would like to utilize the model for their
own purposes without commercial
use of that,
then it is allowed per the license.
But I also am not strong on the legal part, so there are
others-
Sean, can you answer that question?
Oh, he's just leaving. No, he's going to answer it.
Sean Sweeney from ACR.
Not really.
Oh, there you go.
There we go. Sean Sweeney, ACR, honorary lawyer.
That's not a joke.
So the Creative Commons license actually is misinterpreted a lot.
So it's non-commercial, which means they can't sell it, but you can be a commercial
entity and use it. And in fact, we have a project with a major pharma
company where they're deploying it across 20
different sites
in one of their major studies, and we happen to be a data node in that study as
well. And Jen is actually leading that
customization for them and the training of those additional sites.
So
we are serious about our commitment to open everything, and we want
anyone and everyone to use it because the use case you've been hearing is that
if the data isn't collected in the same way or at least with appropriate
metadata that we can map together, you still don't have the statistical power
you need. So we want everyone to use it, modify it.
It's just that we want you to share your modifications back, and you can't sell it.
That's it. But you can be a commercial entity and use it. We would love that.
Absolutely.
And on that note, one more reminder, if you want to see this model
live in action today or for the rest of the conference, the place to
go is the Sail Pavilion. So in that
big space, there is a dedicated ACR Genie booth,
and there will be demos there. So thanks so much.
Hope you look and check it out. And thanks again for attending.
Have a good rest of your conference. Thanks.